New York City is fascinating for
architecture and it's a great place for
an architect to live
take it in their mood no don't work in a
number of other projects for top clients
in the future but this one will really
stand out in Singapore it's not a matter
of whether to put up a multi-story
building but how high it's going to be
the New York borough of Manhattan is one
of the most densely populated urban
areas on earth nearly 6,000 skyscrapers
are crammed onto an island that measures
just under 88 square kilometers is this
what all big cities are going to look
like one day more people more traffic
more energy used how can life in big
cities like this be improved it's a
difficult question for architects urban
planners and sociologists alike
my name is Blake Rasik and I am an
architect in New York City I studied
architecture at the University of
Illinois and I've lived in New York City
for three-and-a-half years now I like
New York City because of the energy and
the number of people and the urbanity of
it because Manhattan is so dense the
only room for growth for buildings is to
build up and I've always loved tall
buildings as a child I've always been
fascinated skyscrapers and Manhattan is
just the quintessential place to be if
you want to build a tall building
because there just isn't any room to
grow there's always a lot of work in
Manhattan for architects these days
they're trying to make their designs
more environmentally friendly whether
they're renovating an old structure or
working out the plans for a new one
Caressa has come up with a radical new
idea a high-rise structure that's
designed for agricultural use right in
the middle of the city so this is was
trying to find out
a renewable you know I've always had an
interest in agriculture gardening so at
being outside so I thought this would be
an interesting way to integrate
architecture and a building and I've
always loved skyscrapers so I thought
vertical farming would be a perfect
marriage of both agriculture and
architecture thoracics design for a 120
story eco tower incorporates not only
modern elements of architectural design
but also traditional agricultural themes
farming vertically is more advantageous
than farming horizontally for the same
reason why in large cities we build tall
buildings for the same reason we build
tall buildings and skyscrapers you would
build a farm in a skyscraper format
vertically so that you don't take up too
much space down at the ground level and
you can be more efficient with your land
use
Kasich is on his way to the southern tip
of Manhattan where one of the most
distinctive skyscrapers in the Western
world is now under construction he's got
an appointment with Udo cloggers CEO of
the American affiliate of the German
company Paul one of the world's leading
manufacturers of metal construction
panels those panels are a key element of
the structures glass and steel facade is
one of the most prestigious contracts in
the company's history we were familiar
with the original design concept for the
high side panels but of course you've
also got taken to account the various
technical elements that are involved in
the actual construction including the
structural elements reinforcement
leveling the evenness of the surface and
so forth that requires a certain level
of expertise which we have in Germany
they gave us the contract because they
were more interested in quality than
cost mr. price by the time the One World
Trade Center structure is completed in
2013 it will be the tallest building in
the Western Hemisphere rising just over
541 metres above the streets of lower
Manhattan the tower will also be one of
the most energy-efficient buildings of
its kind
Panama City is located at the Pacific
entrance of the world-famous canal the
capital of Panama has experienced rapid
economic growth in recent years and with
the expansion have come the usual urban
complications more people and more
vehicles
Panama City features the highest
concentration of high-rise buildings in
Latin America they've been built in
imitation of structures in the United
States in defiance of local
architectural traditions and
environmental concerns but now that's
changing architect Gustavo Arango is
taking part in a program that's aimed at
encouraging a more sustainable approach
to building design and construction but
because of the region's unique geography
Arango sees no alternative two
skyscrapers are on go under colleague
real estate broker Carla Lopez ABEO says
that public awareness of environmental
issues is growing in Panama City see no
end of percent or lost 90% of the
high-rise buildings in Panama City our
residential tower blocks the rest of
hotels or office buildings the reason
for that is simple construction space
was and is quite limited but one of the
advantages of having all these high-rise
structures is that they house a lot of
people so the city spends less on
infrastructure things like streets and
electric and water utilities that means
that high-rises actually represent a
more efficient and sustainable
alternative tierra a local mass Austin
Talia
but the office skyscrapers with their
glass facades do use a lot of energy for
air-conditioning which is essential
given Panama's tropical climate such
buildings may be visually striking but
they're not exactly environmentally
friendly
still one business is bucking the trend
Morgan and Morgan is one of Panama
City's most successful companies and
it's investing in a showcase
construction project that addresses a
number of environmental concerns the
design will be produced here
Eduardo Quintero studied in Miami and
then honed his skills by working in the
offices of a prominent American
architect Quintero and his wife interior
designer
Anna Maria Sam banya jumped at the
opportunity to create an innovative
high-rise structure that will also be
environmentally friendly company for the
creativa is committed to the
implementation of green concepts and
sustainability we believe this is an
important part of architectural design
fortunately my concept for this project
matched that of the clients so we didn't
have to win them over that was a big
relief it's quite satisfying for me to
work on a project that is raising the
standard of local architecture and is
also taking environmental concerns into
account it's a brilliant concept Juan
Felipe de la iglesia is Morgan and
Morgan's chief representative on the
project he's well aware that
construction costs will run 10% higher
than average but Morgan executives
believe that those costs will be far
outweighed by the positive publicity
that this groundbreaking concept will
generate among the company's
international clients
a green construction project of a very
different kind is underway in New York
City blinker assic has been invited to
have a look at one of the city's rooftop
farms a small tract of rural tranquility
located at the top of an old multi-story
industrial building local residents are
encouraged to help out in the garden
this is basically a simplified version
of classics vertical farm concept
the rooftop farm is owned and operated
by anastasiya coldplay kiyose tell me
about the roof how large is it and what
kind of things do grow and we do
something we are standing on an acre
roof it's about 40,000 feet square feet
and we grow about 16 to 20,000 pounds of
produce every year we sell a lot of
restaurants we also sell a lot to the
community so you want things that are a
little off the beaten path that chefs
get excited about but you also want
things that your average family can
bring home for dinner and cook in their
kitchen at a number of similar projects
have sprung up around New York there's
plenty of room for them too considering
all the empty roof space the city
authorities are actively supporting this
kind of farming existing ecosystem one
that self sustaining self perpetuating
and can really be healthy with minimal
intervention rooftop farms have many
advantages they help reduce co2
emissions reduce the ambient temperature
in summer and they use rainwater
we really wanted to explore urban
agriculture as a fiscally sustainable
industry I believe that rooftop farming
is an essential part of the city's
future and an urban agriculture in
general it will never replace its rural
counterparts Korsak is convinced that
his concept could provide at least a
portion of the agricultural products
consumed in New York on a daily basis
but the idea is still a little ahead of
its time vertical farming as I've
depicted it will be realized at the
point when farming in the city becomes
economical and when energy prices and
other obstacles get in the way of the
current situation of our food production
system then it will be more cost
effective to build a vertical farm and
so as a result vertical farms will
follow yes it definitely could be a
solution even in Manhattan even though
the prices are exorbitant lehigh in
Manhattan and hen real estate is
notorious for expense but this is where
all the people are this is where the
most of the people are in the United
States so this is the perfect place for
a vertical fund an eco tower like this
could one day produce as much food as
1,000 hectares of farmland I think that
vertical farms and hydroponic rooftop
farms underground aquaponic operations
these are all essential pieces of the
same puzzle how do we create a more
sustainable way of living in cities in
the 21st century
this variation on the theme of
environmentally-sound urban architecture
was developed by belgian architect
Marisol Kabul a fully self-sufficient
ecosystem that rises 600 meters above an
island in New York's East River many
experts believe quite literally that the
sky's the limit when it comes to modern
structural architecture and new designs
will likely include elements that will
allow people to live in greater harmony
with the natural environment many of the
mega cities of tomorrow can be found
today in Asia and they have the
skyscrapers to prove it take for example
the city-state of Singapore which covers
just over 700 square kilometres there's
no place for the buildings to go but up
and they're built close together
Singapore is one of the world's most
highly developed market economies and is
also a leading international financial
center it continues to attract foreign
companies that want to expand into Asian
markets
but despite its rampant vertical
construction sprawl Singapore is also
the region's most environmentally
friendly city shedding Terra's brine
hold works for the respected Singapore
architects whoo-ha where she's designing
a public housing facility the structure
must provide generous living space and
affordable rent it's also got to be
cost-effective to maintain and
environmentally friendly and it must
take into account Singapore's tropical
climate the classical house the classic
design of a high-rise structure was
developed in the West which has a
completely different climate those
compact design simply won't work here in
the tropics they're not appropriate for
Singapore's climate so we're trying to
develop a new type of high-rise that has
a more relaxed design one that's more
porous increases a circulation of fresh
air and interacts more effectively with
the climate we're trying to design
high-rise buildings that are more
sustainable and that use artificial
climate control as little as possible
this concept of environmental
sustainability plays a key role in our
designs in this project for example it's
represented in features that include sky
streets and sky gardens as we call them
in short we make use of horizontal
design elements in a vertical format
Faraz brine Rose has adapted concepts
from an earlier whoo-ha design project
the award-winning 36 story Newton Suites
residential tower its distinctive
features include water gardens green
common areas specially designed
balconies and patterned exterior panels
the tower also makes use of rooftop
planning sky gardens and vine covered
exterior walls that more than compensate
for the ground the building takes up
people shouldn't have to go without
these green elements just because they
live in a compact urban environment by
including sky gardens and open spaces in
our design plan we've managed to
maintain a connection between a
high-rise Tower and a surrounding
environment even on the top floors each
of the towers residential units features
a small balcony Gardner the gardens are
popular with the residents but they pale
in comparison to the structure is most
unusual
Green element yamir here for instance
creeper vines cover the blank walls on
the facade from the top of the building
to the bottom we've developed a number
of low tech features for this project in
the case of the facade covering it's
just a series of plant troughs that
contain the vines it's not very
complicated and the plants don't require
any special maintenance League of Adar
photo because on this complex you
principales Vista in principle it's
important to provide shade for the
building facades in tropical areas like
ours because it's the facades not the
roof that absorb the most heat from the
Sun so the facades need to be covered at
Newton Suites we've installed woven wire
mesh both horizontally and vertically
this screens out the sunlight without
blocking the residents view of the city
Panama City aims to enhance its role is
one of Latin America's leading cities
when it comes to protecting the
environment but unlike in Singapore the
government here is not directly involved
with construction
Eduardo Quintero and Juan Felipe de la
iglesia on their way to a construction
site a few kilometers northeast of
Panama City's main business district the
MMG tower the building is located in the
new development zone that features a lot
of open space and green areas
the MMG tower was designed to reduce
energy consumption green areas on the
roof will help mitigate the extra heat
that's generated by the rest of the city
solar panels will also enhance energy
conservation the design makes use of
natural light and ventilation to create
an optimal office environment the MMG
tower is also the city's first high-rise
built of structural steel most similar
buildings use concrete frame
construction one of the advantages of
using steel is that the large sections
of the structure can be prefabricated
that speeds construction and there
aren't any bulky concrete supports to
block the view MMG chose this site
specifically because it would complement
the environmentally friendly office
tower that they plan to build Ganassi
walkin and morgan decided that they
wanted to build a new office tower but
they also wanted a structure that was
green and sustainable they're the
largest law practice in Central America
and they wanted to demonstrate their
commitment to protecting the environment
we'll do that in addition we wanted our
design to qualify for top certification
by the US Green Building Council he said
if we got a lock on a visually gold they
went the extra mile to come up with an
appropriate design that's one of the
reasons why we decided to use
non-traditional construction methods
about 85% of the steel that we used came
from recycling sources all we need to do
now is to give it its fire protection
the building council's seal of approval
takes into account not only the
materials used in construction its
structural design but also whether the
building has been designed to use energy
efficiently Quintero explains some of
the towers energy saving features the
elevators here for example are fitted
with a unique energy regeneration system
so they use a lot less energy than
conventional designs do the system is
very energy efficient it's also
important for all the facade elements to
be well insulated the windows are
specially treated so they don't allow a
lot of heat to get into the building
that's very important here because we
have a lot of sunshine
it's a very demanding project and not
just because the first time we designed
I have a lot of international experience
so I know how architectural designs vary
from place to place but this is my first
opportunity to complete a project for a
big client in my home country it's
simply fantastic
more than five million people live in
Singapore that's about four times the
population of Panama City's metro area
most of Singapore's residents live in
high-rise buildings how can the people
who design these buildings help to
maintain or even improve the quality of
life in large Asian cities the whoo-hah
architectural firm was founded by one
one son and in Australian colleague
Richard hassel they specialize in
creating alternative solutions that
bring their high-rise buildings into
greater harmony with the surrounding
urban environment and not soulless steel
and glass structures that gobble energy
like there is no tomorrow
the most distinctive feature of
buildings designed by whoo-hah is the
greening of the external facade openings
and meeting rooms a concert hall
theaters and classrooms all under one
roof it's called sandwich and it's
energy efficient as Cheddington ozb
Ranaut explains the main parts of the
building were designed to maximize
natural ventilation so that even if
there's no wind's blowing outside
there'll always be a breeze inside we
also use natural ventilation in the
classrooms ceiling fans instead of air
conditioners there are also breeze ways
between the individual structures and
that also contributes to the natural
ventilation
most of the energy that's consumed in
the world's tropical regions is used to
power cooling systems but simple changes
to the architecture can create natural
ventilation systems that work so well
that air conditioning isn't needed a
good example of this can be found at
another high-rise structure designed by
whoo-ha
more main rise it counted a bay window
the monsoon window alright so this top
layer is just to prevent small things
from dropping true and then the second
layer is the slider and this is a slider
that allows you to open and close the
window and then you have the safety bars
and that's to prevent the size of 100
millimeter diameter ball from falling
true so that's a safety barrier so the
rain would come in but only yes only the
breeze would come in so the system
monsoon window that allows natural
ventilation 24 hours a day 365 days a
year and you'd really don't have to
worry about running to close a window
and it rings so we can see at a higher
level you you get the breeze and the
breeze is actually quite nice and strong
and slightly drier and lower perhaps
there are a few things that we can now
with this implementer we know what's the
problems with it and we can actually
improve them one of the things is
actually acoustic by opening the windows
in this way too we also allow some of
the noise to come up and this is
something that we think that we would
like to address as well this is Wong's
grand design for the city of the future
an integrated system of high-rises that
offers a sustainable environment for
homes and businesses
if you try to create a high density
solution you do have to go high-rise and
we really think what is really necessary
is to duplicate the city not on one
ground level but to replicate this on to
higher levels and into multiple levels
and you can see from from this rendering
to is that we have almost 200 to 250
stories and but what is really quite
important is within this lattice City at
this kind of height to get the quality
of good fresh air and natural light
sunlight is actually very important for
the city high-rise buildings are
undergoing a major transition in design
as architects develop new ways to
increase sustainability and energy
efficiency the world's major urban areas
will continue to reach for the sky but
the structures that dominate the skyline
will take on an increasingly green
character ecological high-rise
architecture is the buzzword and a key
technology for the future